oh my god i can't believe i'm doing this
[Music]
i mean i am actually leaving my family
uh but i'm coming back on monday because
i am going on an all girls bachelorette
party to exuma bahamas
[Music]
i am very excited because i desperately
need a vacation but i'm also low-key
kind of anxious because i've never left
my husband alone with both kids for more
than like a few hours while i work i
don't know why i'm nervous i mean my
husband is completely capable he's a
very hands-on dad um and even though our
like domestic responsibilities aren't
necessarily equal in a lot of ways i
would say that they are pretty fair so a
lot of things that he does for the
household are things that i'm not good
at or don't want to do and vice versa so
we kind of just make it work having said
that i do tend to take on a lot of the
thankless mundane invisible tasks that
nobody sees or nobody talks about or
nobody notices but that make the family
unit run so in today's vlog i'm going to
take you guys behind the scenes as i try
to get myself ready for this vacation
and also get my family ready for my
absence too and i'm gonna quickly just
throw up my disclaimer and a reminder
that this is my routine this is not
something that should be duplicated or
copied and if you are not already
subscribed hit that subscribe button and
follow me over on tick tock and
instagram abby's kitchen okay so one of
the the tasks i have left my husband
with this weekend when i go away other
than obviously the task of taking care
of our two children is
two
birthday parties so i normally do the
birthday party circuit with my son and
it's like that time of year i don't know
spring
and early summer a lot of babies
apparently so we've had like two to four
birthday parties every weekend since
they allowed us to have birthday parties
here in in ontario so we've got two
birthday parties that he's gonna have to
go to obviously i had to go get all the
gifts because he would have completely
dropped the ball on that what the hell
are you talking about
um so i already wrapped up one of them
i've got another little piece here to go
in that it's a
um
who is this a black panther black
panther costume my son has the whole uh
collection of
uh avengers
kind of costumes he's really into dress
up so i figured this other little kid
might like that too so i got him and for
our other little friends
um it's an art themed birthday party so
i got her more kind of like artistic
like
toys and activities so
look how fun this is
like i want to make a unicorn out of
mold paint and glitter so i'm tempted to
keep this one for myself but i am in a
giving mood and i don't want to go back
to the store
but while i was there i also picked up a
little activity for e
this will hopefully keep him busy for
like a good 15 minutes we're really into
painting we're really into the idea of
fairies and other kind of um mythical
creatures like unicorns and things like
that so i thought if we could build a
little fairy garden for him i think he'd
be pretty jazzed and that's a good
activity to do with the kiddo while i'm
gone so i'm going to
wrap up these little gifts
i could have sworn we had like more
actual wrapping paper and i probably do
downstairs but i don't want to have to
go back downstairs into the basement so
gift bags it is so much easier and just
like kids love tissue paper am i wrong
tell me i'm wrong
spiderman for the win
look at this wrapping paper oh
suddenly this is like an asmr video i
mean tell me you don't like the sound of
this
[Music]
you're either in heaven or you want to
die so please let me know in the
comments below how you feel about the
sound of
crinkling paper i'm just happy that
we're done and that was painless and
easy i loki
love buying children's gifts and
wrapping them it's just like what a
pleasure to see their little cute faces
i'm happy my husband doesn't want to
take that job away from me
it is a beautiful day so i am walking
to my wax appointment
and to get my nails done
the first of which is never really a fun
appointment but
hopefully we'll be quick all right folks
this is the not so fun part of my day
kelly clarkson at least it was fast now
let's go make up for it with a little
spot time
[Music]
all right this looks so much better
uh oh my gosh my nose is all crinkled up
from my my mask uh i've got a boogie
home now because it looks like it's
going to rain any second now and your
girl does not have an umbrella obviously
so
okay so now we have to do a little
packing okay so normally i hate packing
but i'm actually kind of excited about
this so
let's get to it
[Music]
okay so i just got a really quick
instacart delivery here because i just
did a full grocery shop two days ago
where i buy an enormous amount of fruit
and our our fridges packed and now we
have no fruit already so i knew that was
going to become a problem over the
weekend if i was not here to keep tabs
on the fruit situation so i had to do an
emergency order knowing my family i'm
probably going to have to be placing
another order while i'm down so but yeah
as long as they're well fed that's all
that matters and speaking of well-fed i
figured i should pre-prep some snacks
for the boys let's do it
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
i feel quite accomplished now with some
snacks
ready for the kiddos to go um but now i
feel like i need to uh get a little bit
of work done for myself before i go on a
holiday
crazy thought i know okay so i figure a
good thing to do before i go is like
organize all my pill packs
because i have a ginormous mess of
supplements here and i feel like i
probably don't actually need all of them
out here so i can put some of them away
because i'm always kind of rotating
through new protocols but
this is a big job so
i'm going to show you how i do it
[Music]
so i had to go get my winter coat
because it is apparently winter outside
here in toronto canada likes to work
with us like that so i had to go get my
winter coat out of storage which i put
away because i thought we were done with
this
apparently not um but anyways i'm going
to go walk to get my hair blown out that
i look a little bit more fresh tomorrow
on the plane than i likely feel because
both of my kids are home
sick
yes help me i'm poor no please pray for
me that i actually get to go on this
trip and if not at least my hair will
look nice for the weekend i am back from
the arctic and i like power walked the
whole way because it was freezing
outside but at least my hair looks good
and a lot of you guys asked me about the
secrets to my curls so i'm gonna tell
you i just have someone else do it for
me because they are the experts at hair
i am not i just know how to apply the
dry shampoo and brush it out in the days
that follow all right lovelies well wish
me luck as excited as i am i also feel
so
riddled with guilt right now
like i even feel guilty for just feeling
excited to leave i mean i feel guilty
when i have to leave the kids just to
like go to work but leaving for a few
days for just like frivolous fun is like
a whole other level of mom guilt and i'm
so mad at myself i feel like a hypocrite
because i tell people all the time how
important it is to have a healthy and
happy mom in order to help to foster a
happy family you know we have to put our
own air mask and life jacket on first
before we can help our kids but it's
also just really hard to actively
embrace that and believe it with all of
your heart in real life it's just hard
to shake that feeling that i'm just not
doing enough ugh i wish i was a dad dads
have a good life
they better be serving booze on this
like 8 a.m flight because i'm gonna need
it i'm not having a glass of wine i'm
having six it's called a tasting and
it's classy
but here's to putting our life jacket on
first and embracing those moments to
refresh and engage in true self-care
your girl needs this like no other so on
that note if you guys liked this video
please give it the thumbs up subscribe
if you haven't already and leave me a
comment below if you have other topics
or things you want to do a vlog on or
another video on and i will see you next
time on abby's kitchen hopefully with a
little tan
[Music]